[Musique]
le sixième rapport d'évaluation du GIEC
le Groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat vient d'être
publié il vient clore un cycle de
travaux commençait en 2015 et concerne
l'épreuve physique du réchauffement
climatique ces impacts et les mesures
d'atténuation qui peuvent être prises
malgré les conclusions alarmantes le
rapport se veut encourageant et livre
des solutions d'atténuation et
d'adaptation réalisable efficace et peu
coûteuse Jean Jouzel Paleo climatologue
ancien membre du GIEC et directeur de
recherche émérite au CEA Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique à livrer sa propre
lecture du rapport il porte également un
discours d'espoir pour lui il est encore
temps d'agir si l'action est immédiate
le premier Forum départemental dédié aux
métiers de la petite enfance aura lieu
ce jeudi 23 mars à l'Hôtel de Ville de
Versailles à destination des étudiants
demandeurs d'emploi ou personnes en
reconversion professionnelle il
proposera tout au long de l'après-midi
de découvrir ces métiers avec des
professionnels du secteur plusieurs
centres de formation du territoire
seront également présents les visiteurs
auront la possibilité de postuler à des
offres plusieurs recruteurs seront sur
place
près de 200 personnes se sont
rassemblées samedi 18 mars devant le
siège de l'UNESCO à Paris devant le
bâtiment des dizaines de baguettes de
pain brandy comme symbole la raison
alerté sur la menace que fait peser la
construction des lignes 17 Nord et 18
ouest du Grand Paris Express sur les
terres céréalières de Gonesse et de
Saclay plus de 3000 hectares pourraient
être détruits les personnes présentes
portées par les collectifs contre la
ligne 18 et pour le Triangle de Gonesse
demande le classement de ses sols au
Patrimoine Mondial de l'Humanité le
samedi 19 mars c'était le jour
anniversaire du cesser le feu en Algérie
cette journée permet chaque année de
commémorer les accords d'Évian du 18
mars 1962 des cérémonies se sont
déroulées dans plusieurs communes des
Yvelines pour rendre hommage à toutes
les victimes civiles ou militaires
tombées durant la guerre à la verrière
le maire Nicolas Dainville était
accompagné de plusieurs membres de la
Fédération Nationale des Anciens
combattants en Algérie
le lundi 20 mars le début de la saison
du printemps ce sera ce soir à 22h24 et
24 secondes heure française et non le 21
mars comme on est habitué la raison
l'équinoxe de printemps c'est-à-dire le
moment où le soleil est parfaitement
aligné avec l'équateur la durée du jour
est alors aussi longue que celle de la
nuit c'est à cette heure qui déterminait
le passage au printemps
[Musique]